i know the change can be scary but it
can also be exciting
if i learned anything from meeting
princess on a billboard is that
sometimes you just have to take a leap
let's start our new life
pretty soon this whole place will feel
like home you'll see
it's all part of the adventure that's
not an adventure that's a landfill a
land filled with adventure
nancy edwards robert congratulations oh
it's what they call a fixer-upper yes
once your peasants have dug out the moat
and added a turret and a balcony from
which you can sing i see it now
okay
melvina monroe i would have sold you
this house but i deal in slightly more
upscale
the hardest part of life is finding your
happily ever after this world is very
different
if this world is not to your liking then
you must change it i wish
[Music]
i wish
jumping jelly sticks wait how am i
talking
i wish
[Music]
i wish for a fairytale life and it's all
gone terribly wrong
or terribly right
at the last stroke of twelve nothing
will be as it was before
[Music]
oh giselle what have you done
that's a wicked wicked good
[Music]
you